pues sin duda todo otro piano puede ser
destituido así que esto se hace sobre
todo para dejar un precedente y para
evitar que en el futuro pueda aspirar a
cargos públicos lo que está pasando es
que ya hay un asesor de hecho un asesor
político de la administración pasada que
está en el congreso presionando a los
republicanos para que no voten a favor
del impeachment amenazándolos de alguna
manera con que el presidente de trump
les quite su apoyo si éstos quieren
aspirar a una reelección en el senado en
los próximos años así que pues por parte
de donald trump si le puede afectar para
la aspiración a un cargo público pero
hay que tener en cuenta que dos tercios
de la cámara alta- dos tercios del
senado tiene que aprobar este
impeachment y en este momento las sillas
son cincuenta para demócratas y
encuentra para republicanos así que lo
hace bastante difícil que el impeachment
pues tenga buen futuro tenga buen fruto
teniendo en cuenta que se necesitan dos
tercios es decir diecisiete republicanos
casi que tendrían que votar
a favor de este ímpetu para joe biden
pues simplemente es todo un mes todo el
mes de febrero perdido porque los
senadores estarán enfocados en el juicio
político